did you know that these hip-hop Legends
went to high school together Jay-Z
Biggie Smalls and Busta Rhymes all
attended George Westinghouse career in
Technical High School in downtown
Brooklyn Busta Rhymes and Jay-Z actually
had a rap battle in the cafeteria both
Jay and Buster admit that Jay-Z won the
battle
Busta Rhymes said they were
experimenting with speed rap which took
less influence from New York hip-hop and
more influence from Jamaican dancehall
artists like Lieutenant stitchy and
Papasan
when the two high schoolers faced off in
the lunchroom Busta Rhymes said he had
just started experimenting with speed
rap Jay-Z had already mastered it but
today it's supposed to Rhymes who's
known for his fast verses on his hit
songs so we think it will be fun to see
the rematch today